una volta sogna di essere una tartaruga
gigante con scheletro d'avorio che
trascinava bimbi e piccini e alghe e
rifiuti e fiori e tutti si aggrappavano
a me sulla mia scorza dura
era una tartaruga che barcollava sotto
il peso dell'amore molto lenta capire e
svelta benedire così figli miei una
volta vi hanno buttato nell'acqua e voi
vi siete aggrappati al mio guscio e vi
ho portato in salvo perché questa
testuggine marina e la terra che vi
salva dalla morte dell'acqua questa è
una poesia che alda merini ha dedicato
all'isola di lampedusa
l'isola di lampedusa è un enorme
tartaruga in mezzo al mare dove ci si
può aggrappare
è una tartaruga che
barcolla sotto il peso dell'amore dei
suoi abitanti
storicamente si narra che nel settecento
un eremita avesse costruito due grotte
una accanto all'altra
dove potessero andare a pregare
cristiani e musulmani uno accanto
all'altro e le avesse addobbate con gli
elementi e simboli delle due religioni
lampedusa è da sempre un porto franco
se le navi e gli equipaggi se le danno
di santa ragione nel mare quando si
arrivava a lampedusa perché si scappava
da una tempesta o per rifocillarsi a
lampedusa alle armi venivano de poste a
lampedusa fiera quasi amici poi si
ripartiva è di nuovo lì se ne dava di
santa ragione ma lampedusa no a
lampedusa storicamente se uno schiavo
riusciva a scappare ed arrivava
sull'isola era libero e il padre non
poteva più farne nulla
in questo momento è da anni a lampedusa
c'è un centro che chiamiamo di primo
soccorso e accoglienza ma di accogliente
non sa nulla
è un centro che può contenere più o meno
250 persone in realtà spesso ce ne sono
state anche 1000 1200 donne uomini e
bambini ammazzati insieme in condizioni
di promiscuità sono i sopravvissuti del
mare sono quelli che hanno fatto il
cosiddetto viaggio della speranza che
hanno attraversato deserti torture abusi
e violazioni
prigionia
stupri che hanno attraversato il mare è
quasi tutti hanno visto qualcuno morire
nel mare e che sono arrivati vivi sono
persone che quando tu vedi arrivare
non penseresti mai di loro la parola
disperato
quando li vedi la parola che tv nera
delle labbra e eroe
queste persone sono degli eroi queste
persone sono portatori sani di speranza
e sono portatori sani di uno dei più
sacri dei diritti che il diritto
all'asilo che è garantito anche dalla
nostra costituzione che è un bell
esempio di bellezza a lampedusa c'è
questo centro dove i sopravvissuti nel
mare vengono rinchiusi vengono buttati
spesso a dormire per terra i più
fortunati hanno dei giacigli di gomma
prima grezza e delle coperte di carta i
più sfortunati neanche quelli e stanno
rinchiusi non posso che potrebbe
contenere 250 persone ma sono 1.200 a
volte i bagni non sono studiati per
1.200 persone si intasano subito l'acqua
nell'isola e salata e tutti la v con
l'acqua salata c'è il sole specie se sei
di pelle scura specie se non ero sapone
specie se non hai una crema ti pieghi e
anche la pelle dei bambini si piega e
viene devastato dalle punture di tutti
gli insetti comprese le pulci e sta lì
dei giorni delle settimane ora meno ma
fino all'anno scorso il record era stato
92 giorni di prigionia in un
centro che è un enorme gabbia circondato
da tutte le forze dell'ordine che vi
vengono in mente polizia carabinieri
guardia di finanza buon peso esercito e
voi pensate per chi scappa perché un
disertore scappa dall'esercito passare
quel tempo circondato da tutte queste
uniformi armate e i bambini giocano tra
queste uniformi dentro il centro e hanno
una pistola ad altezza avviso è
una delle ultime volte che c'era stata
c'erano buon peso servano infilato
dentro anche tre cani randagi che si
scannavano tra di loro i bambini avevano
preso le pulci dei cani
in questo centro
tutte le volte che viene distrutto
perché voi immaginate 1.200 persone
dentro dopo un po è una polveriera nou
esplode e allora in questo centro ogni
volta che viene distrutto viene
ricostruito ma nella rete di recinzione
mira il centro ha lasciato un buco
sempre anche adesso lo hanno ricostruito
e hanno lasciato un buco perché è una
scelta intelligente ipocritamente di
gente no non possiamo non dovremmo
imprigionare queste persone non dovremmo
imprigionando e 1200 non dovremmo tenere
la mazzata per settimane o mesi
e allora quel buco e uno sfiatatoio le
persone escono dal buco
una piccola evasione ma in realtà non
dovrebbero essere rinchiusi il regale e
chi li rinchiude non è scappare da un
centro di accoglienza che dovrebbe
essere aperto loro escono dal centro e
vanno dalle piccole tartarughe di
lampedusa vanno nella via centrale
dell'isola che via roma dove i
lampedusani offrono l'accoglienza vera e
c'è questo piccolo spaccio clandestino
in via roma dove i lampedusani
intanto lasciano pagati nei bar il caffè
holt e per chiunque passerà dirà e poi
distribuiscono tutto cibo vestiti scarpe
e sapone crema è tutto perché nel centro
non distribuivano niente perché ma no
col sapone potrebbero uccidersi con le
ciabatte potrebbero uccidersi pieno di
gente che si ammazza ciabattata
e
nella via invece no l'accoglienza sanno
che cos'è e distribuiscono i giochi per
i bambini e distribuiscono sorrisi ma
quando il sole tramonta queste persone
non hanno un altro posto e quindi
tornano nel centro e si presentano
all'ingresso principale dicono va beh ci
fate entrare e no no tu non sei mai
uscito quindi io non ti posso far
entrare rientra dal buco e rientrano dal
buco e vanno avanti così per tutto il
tempo della della loro prigionia a
lampedusa nella cosiddetta emergenza
araba c'è stato un momento
2011 nella primavera che in cui
sull'isola c'erano 6 mila profughi
giovanissimi tra l'altro quasi tutti
tunisini
gli abitanti dell'isola sono 6 mila
persone
voi immaginate l'impatto ed erano tutti
sul molo e l'accoglienza dello stato
italiano era tale per cui ci siamo
dimenticati persino i portali cessi però
c'erano i lampedusani e i lampedusani
hanno distribuito tutto coperte acqua
cibo tutto la sera si era la
distribuzione del cibo davanti nella
piazza principale davanti alla chiesa e
in abitazioni mi hanno invitato a
entrare nelle loro case ea guardare i
loro armati e mi hanno detto guarda noi
non abbiamo una coperta in più un
maglione in più un paio di scarpe in più
rispetto a quelle che abbiamo addosso
perché è normale
se noi fossimo costretti a scappare e
andare dall'altra sponda del mare ci
sarebbero altre madri e altri padri che
ci darebbero le loro coperte i loro
manzoni le loro scarpe è normale
quando è stato proposto di dare a
lampedusa il premio nobel per la pace la
mia amica paola la rosa in un campeggio
di amnesty international per i diritti
umani che si tiene sull'isola di
lampedusa ha detto ma sapete cosa c'è
noi il nobel non lo vogliamo
perché se voi date il nobel a noi perché
abbiamo distribuito cibo e vestiti e
sorrisi a persone che hanno avuto solo
la sfortuna di nascere dalla a parte del
mare
è come se dicesse che quello che noi
facciamo è straordinario è eccezionale e
da nobel e se dite questo state dicendo
che chi invece ignora chi rinchiude chi
respinge
fa le cose normali state legittimando
chi ignora respinge rinchiude e allora
sapete cosa c'è il nobel noi non lo
vogliamo
date l'ignobel che è molto meglio
a lampedusa arrivano
a lampedusa arrivano i vivi ma arrivano
anche i morti e c'è un'isola un po più
grande
la sicilia dove sono stati distribuiti i
368 morti del naufragio del 3 ottobre
lo stato aveva dichiarato che avrebbe
fatto i funerali di stato non li ha mai
fatti
in realtà hanno fatto una cerimonia in
cui non hanno invitato i parenti delle
vittime non hanno in parte invitato i
sopravvissuti che sono rimasti rinchiusi
nel centro non ho potuto neanche vedere
tumulare i loro fratelli o i loro mariti
hanno pensato bene però erano quasi
tutti i ritrae le vittime hanno pensato
bene di invitare rappresentanti del
governo e il tiro della quale stavano
scappando
allora i funerali quelli veri li hanno
fatto i sindaci dell'agrigentino si sono
messi il vestito bello della festa si
sono messi la fascia tricolore hanno
chiesto agli eritrei dei loro comuni
come celebrare una funzione che non
offendesse ma rispettasse la creatura
che stavano seppellendo e hanno invitato
la cittadinanza
e hanno fatto veramente i funerali di
stato ma l'hanno fatto i loro
singolarmente no e alcuni cittadini
dell'agrigentino hanno dato la forma di
accoglienza che secondo me è la più
straordinaria perché eterna hanno aperto
le loro tombe di famiglia a questi morti
sconosciuti e ne hanno messi insieme ai
loro familiari ai loro cari perché
potessero avere un posto dove qualcuno
comunque andava a mettere un fiore o
andava a versare una lacrima e perché
comunque alcuni di loro mi hanno scritto
se domani si potessero trovare i loro
parenti i loro parenti potrebbero andare
a sapere dove sono e andare a pregarli
ed è una un'accoglienza che non affina e
quindi
non ho mai conosciuto una forma di
questo tipo 16 può fare lo splendido
ospitarsi qualcuno a casa dopo un palo
nonna via dalla tomba di famiglia è
difficile e quindi è veramente
straordinario e
nella sicilia c'è un altro esempio di
straordinaria
e bella accoglienza c'è una comunità che
funziona bene come dovrebbero funzionare
tutte una comunità di accoglienza perché
si chiama i girasoli per i minori
stranieri non accompagnati
i minori stranieri non accompagnati sono
i più piccoli dei piccoli i più fragili
che vi possono venire in mente sono
profughi scappano da guerre persecuzioni
attraversato il deserto la prigione in
mare hanno visto morire qualcuno spesso
sono stati abusati violati stuprati e
sono stranieri quindi non voluti i
reietti
e sono soli sono non accompagnati sono
soli quel viaggio ne hanno fatto da soli
e e arrivano qua e hanno 14 15 anni
magari iniziato a scappare che ne
avevano 10 e arrivano qua magari salvati
dalle nostre navi
della guardia costiera che sono un altro
straordinario esempio di bellezza e
arrivano nelle nostre coste vengono
limitati nelle nostre coste e spesso i
primi giorni di passano in
campi da calcio in parchi e abbandonati
non sono neanche che sono in italia
vengono perquisiti ovunque gli vengono
prese le impronte digitali e
vengono trattati più come invasori che
come bambini e dopo un po di giorni
vengono messi in comunità
spesso le comunità non sono adeguati a
loro spesso sono in promiscuità con
adulti e in questa comunità invece le
cose funzionano i bambini vengono
trattati come bambini ei ragazzini come
i ragazzini vengono iscritti
immediatamente a scuola e questo è
e molto educativo per i nostri ragazzi
perché questi bambini vanno a scuola
parlano per gli altri ragazzini è
iniziato tu cosa fai durante il giorno
meglio gioca a calcio la playstation e
tu che cosa hai fatto
ma io ho attraversato il deserto sono
stato un po in prigione in libia poi ho
preso una barca ha però è l'approccio è
diverso
beh non sei disperato sei un eroe e in
questo in questo sistema di integrazione
hanno pensato con le garante
dell'infanzia di chiedere a questi
ragazzi che erano appena arrivati di
fare con noi con degli educatori e con
dei fumettisti
un kit di da distribuire agli altri
ragazzi che potevano arrivare
come loro che potevano sbarcare in
sicilia o in calabria e gli hanno detto
fai finta che e non è tanto una finta
purtroppo fai finta che tuo fratello tu
sarai il lato cugino il tuo migliore
amico sbarchi adesso tu che cosa volevi
sapere quando sei arrivato quali
informazioni ti sono mancate
e scrivere tu per tu o fratello e tua
sorella dirgli che cosa li aspetterà
e allora mi hanno detto che non arrivati
in italia banalmente no gli hanno detto
di portare pazienza perché siamo in
italia e quindi sì ci sono dei diritti
ma porta pazienza e ogni tre o quattro
pagine c'è un orologio e c'è scritto
porta pazienza e e poi il
loro si disegnano no e si presentano
dicono noi siamo abdul
eccetera eccetera
e tu benvenuto e gli raccontano che le
divise da noi
dovrebbero essere democratiche che
comunque non sono come quelle da cui
stanno scappando
gli dicono che possono andare a scuola
mi dicono che possano andare in ospedale
gli dicono che se sono piccole sono
state abusate sono incinte possono anche
abortire gli spiegano tutti i loro
diritti con parole semplici e con
disegni e l'orologio porta pazienza e
poi hanno disegnato anche noi che
eravamo lì a un certo punto è il abbiamo
chiesto perché fondamentalmente siamo
commerciali e allora io abbiamo detto ma
se noi facciamo questo kit e lo
distribuiamo a chi sbarca
voi lo sapete come avete fatto il mare
il deserto prime arrivate siete
completamente sconvolti disorientati vi
diamo una roba in mano voi non capite
cos'è anche se sia il disegno anche se
tra volta lì per lì non capite la
buttate come facciamo in modo
perché questa cosa che vediamo in mano
sia accattivante europei e commerciali e
c'è un colore che vi piace
particolarmente
c'è un materiale che vi piace
particolarmente c'è una forma che vi
piace particolarmente e loro ci hanno
spiazzati e ci hanno detto beh basta che
tu metti la parola dio sulla copertina e
per noi quell'oggetto e sacro non lo
butteremo mai
e
dall'altro vi avevamo anche chiesto che
cosa che loro volevano fare da grandi
perché una cosa che ai minori stranieri
non accompagnati nessuno chiede è come
se loro ne hai già avuto troppo di
futuro infondono sei vivo finisce qua
adesso poi decidiamo noi per te è invece
in questa comunità gli chiedono che cosa
vogliono fare da grandi divi gli
restituiscono i loro sogni e loro ti
dicono le stesse cose che direbbero i
nostri giocare a calcio diventare un
campione e pilotare gli aerei però sul
pilotare gli aerei ti dicono perché così
io torno in africa ei miei fratelli e la
mia mamma quel viaggio in mare io non
glielo faccio fare io riporti in aereo e
quando gli abbiamo chiesto allora come
renderlo sacro abbiamo partorito insieme
questa frase gli abitanti di questa
terra è il tuo dio sono felici che tu
sia arrivato vivo
ci sembrava giusto
riconoscere il dio di tutti e non è
passato perché siamo in italia e quindi
le varie autorità ci hanno detto come il
tuo dio ce n'è più duro così vogliamo
mica mettere in discussione adesso tutto
e quindi è passata con la versione gli
abitanti di questa terra e il cielo sono
felici che tu sia arrivato vivo i
ragazzi ce l'hanno approvato lo stesso e
quindi noi siamo felici che siano
arrivati vivi grazie